I will warn you as you call in today we
have a 21 year Thanksgiving tradition on
the Dave Ramsey show that when you call
in in order to for me to talk to you you
have to tell me something you're
grateful for what do you think FULFILLER
who passed away about this time last
year used to say you need to have an
attitude of gratitude
you need to have something you're
thankful for did you know that grateful
people are extremely attractive you know
what's unattractive
you know what's ugly ungrateful people
and you know the interesting thing about
that is you can decide right this second
ready 1 2 3
I'm grateful you can just be one of
those grateful people starting right now
ready grateful people smile grateful
people aren't stressed grateful people
open the door for other people they have
generous hearts they give grateful
people don't run a hate websites it's
hard to be grateful and hateful you
can't be both at the same time you
really can't if you have a particular
area of your life you're not grateful
for you will become hateful in that area
and you know the interesting thing about
gratitude is not only is it very very
attractive and opens doors for you
because think about who you want to hang
out with when you help someone maybe you
just knew about a guy that was hiring
and you knew another guy that was
looking for a job and you said hey go
over there and talk to George he's
hiring and the guy gets the job and when
he gets the job because you sent him
over there he's grateful and he can't
believe it and for five years he tells
everybody about how cool you were and
how you helped him he was grateful you
know the next time that guy needs
something you're going to break your
back helping him because
is grateful it's fun to help grateful
people it's fun to give a lift to give
an encouragement to connect help them
make money help them get a job help them
open a business it's fun to do things
for grateful people when you're grateful
you're attractive this is an important
holiday in this hateful culture we live
in where everybody's decided it's all
about them walking around looking for a
chance to be offended about something
maybe we just need to be saying thank
you giving thanks gratefulness is
powerful by the way it's an it there's
an interesting correlation here kind of
been studying this lately Rachael and I
wrote a chapter in our book how do you
create children in this go go come
consumerist culture that are content in
a culture where if then that your
happiness is based on the next thing you
buy for everyone else and you're
watching television you're seeing
billboards you're you know people hang
out at the mall for entertainment lord
help us in a culture like that how do
you create children that are content
Rachel and I always talked about it
pride about a lot as we're writing this
book on smart money smart kids teaching
kids money we did a whole chapter on
content children now I'm not talking
about children that aren't ambitious and
I'm not talking about children that
aren't working and I'm not talking about
lazy I'm talking about content there's a
difference a lot of difference and I
don't know if it's the whole answer but
I can tell you that that there's a
there's a correlation very few content
people are ungrateful people
gratefulness has a tendency to create
contentment it's unusual for someone to
be content that's not grateful it's
unusual for
that's grateful to not become in that
process content I'm grateful for my car
Lord I'm grateful for this job you gave
me it makes me content in it because I'm
grateful for it when I'm hateful about
it I'm kind of self-centered selfish
prideful entitled it's kind of the
opposite and those are the most
discontented people on the planet have
you noticed nothing is good enough ever
now there's a difference to be driven to
excellence and and man I'm all about
I've had meetings in my office this
morning where I'm driving the lane man I
know it's the day before Thanksgiving
but we got stuff to do around here we're
stepping and fetching and a couple
people we were working on stuff and I'm
like what the crap you're doing get this
going here that's different that's
coaching that's saying hey go play the
game with excellent strap on a helmet
hits somebody baby this is what it's
about that's different that's not that's
not a lack of contentment that's
excellence and passion though those
things can coexist but contentment is a
state of being in your heart it's a
spiritual experience and it's tied to
your level of gratefulness it's a great
holiday we've got here Thanksgiving it's
a fabulous holiday and I'll go ahead and
take it one step further and I miss
these things up by the way I'm not I'm
not the teacher here sitting here saying
I've got it all figured out I I'm just
kind of studying it it's also it
convicting me and saying the guy in the
mirror can work on these things I'm
grateful but but because I just tell
people all the time if I want me I'd
want to be me I mean really I got a good
life but then there's other times I'm
not and I'm hateful and those are the
times I'm discontented and things
anxious and stressed and worried and
aren't those things tied together do you
feel that is that that's past the common
sense smell test to you folks I bet it
does let's take it one step further
backward if gratefulness creates
contentment or is at least directly tied
to it what creates gratefulness what's a
prerequisite for you to be grateful
this one I'm sure of humility people who
are prideful or seldom grateful people
who are humble are usually grateful and
the humble is not I'm a worm I'm a
doormat I'm awful I'm horrible I'm never
going to be anything I sing those
sermons sing those hymns I'm a worm Lord
I'm worm Lord that's not humble that's
stupid and that's lacking in self-esteem
I'm a king's kid I'm very I'm very happy
to be humble and be a king's kid so
humble is not humiliation rachel has a
great line that she stole from somebody
she says humility is not thinking less
of yourself but thinking let thinking of
yourself less not thinking less of
yourself but thinking of yourself less
you think about others and you know you
didn't the axis of the world really
doesn't run through the top of your head
it's not all about you so when you're
prideful you're seldom grateful and
you're seldom contented when you have a
level of humility it gives you the
ability to be grateful and say thank you
thanks giving giving thanks and that
leads you into contently that's a
financial lesson that's a financial
lesson for Thanksgiving